bonsoir merci d'être avec nous sur
france info café alors voyons le
sommaire de notre émission ce soir la
question d' échec et mat
elle peut-on encore sauver l'école pour
y répondre nous avons réuni pierre
jourde pour fait ça secret et christa
roche qui a écrit proviseur avant de
l'ain le cours de littérature sera donné
ce soir par marc levy
il nous parlera de jacques prévert notre
inattendu sera vous verrez très
inattendu c'est marie sizun
un premier roman les pères de la petite
je dois avouer que j'ai une très grosse
tendresse pour ce roman
sophie jabès dans le ping pong répondra
à une critique acerbe de jérôme béglé à
propos de son dernier roman tuto
motrices almira skripchenko grande
joueuse d'échecs nous donnera dans
décalage sa lecture du chef-d'oeuvre de
nabokov la défense logis enfin le
journal intime de marie darrieussecq
vous la fera découvrir je crois sous un
jour que vous ne connaissez pas
en forme d'hommage ce soir à une grande
dame à une grande dame noire mais je
n'en dis pas plus maintenant
vous connaissez la totalité du sommaire
de l'émission vous propose de rejoindre
l'intérieur
mes premiers invités
[Musique]
notre débat à échec et mat ce soir sera
initiée par par une question peut-on
sauver l'école et pour répondre à cette
question donc nous inviter d'abord qui
un jour je dis tout d'abord parce que
c'est votre livre qui a initié un petit
peu ce débat je parle de festins secret
vous êtes professeur à l'université de
grenoble iii vous êtes né à créteil je
dis ça comme ça parce que ça me fait
plaisir de prononcer le mot créteil
vous avez écrit une quinzaine d'ouvragés
et vous êtes célèbre pour ce fameux
littérature sans estomac en 2002 qui a
réglé son compte à rebours ou de monde
dans la profession je pense que vous
n'êtes pas fait que des amis avec ce
livre
voilà vous avez eu quand même le prix la
critique de l'académie française évoque
un ouvrage qui a été distingué ce roman
raconte la désillusion d'un jeune
professeur qui au cours de sa première
nomination dans une banlieue un peu
lointaine va connaître à peu près tous
les désagréments possibles pour un jeune
enseignant ça c'est un des aspects du
livre
dans ce roman on peut dire vous brosser
un tableau désespérant de l'école on va
voir ce que vous en pensez
en face d'eux en face de vous christa
roche vous êtes la proviseure la
proviseur de ce livre que vous avez
écrit avec luc rozentvaig paru aux
éditions plon proviseur à vaulx en velin
vous avez fait toute votre carrière vous
êtes agrégé de lettres avec vous avez
ensuite rejoint le corps des chefs
d'établissement d'abord
proviseur-adjoint bon et ensuite vous
êtes maintenant proviseur du lycée
doisneau a avoué en venin alors c'est à
vous que je vais poser la question qui
est l'objet du débat
alors est-ce qu'on peut encore sauver
l'école quand on nie le livre de pierre
jourde
on a l'impression que l'école et est
condamné
le problème c'est que le livre de pierre
joue votre livre c'est un roman donc on
peut tout se permettre en littérature
tout se permettre dans l'écriture
romanesque même de dire que l'école
mais plus on peut plus la sauver moi je
ne me pose pas la question comme ça dans
je dirais dans la réalité
je pense qu'il faut simplement la
continuer je me pose pas la question de
savoir si on peut la sauver parce que je
pense qu'elle n'est pas en danger de
mort alors vous juste juste pour situer
quand même votre votre itinéraire vous
êtes dans un lycée difficile on dire
lycées sensibles m'attendais ya plein de
mots pour dire que c'est compliqué d'y
enseigner et on peut dire vous n'aimez
pas ça veut dire que vous avez en tout
cas quand vous êtes arrivé dans ce lycée
prolonger cette ce taux de réussite et
améliorer le taux de réussite à l'examen
c'est à dire que ce que vous y faites a
produit des résultats
ceux qui font les adultes qui
travaillent oui je peux tout seul parce
que si elles pas les yeux sur je ne sais
pas oui ça produit des résultats bien
sûr parce que les élèves aussi en ont
envie oui oui c'est vrai mais c'est pas
un lycée difficile service est
passionnant et les élèves
ils connaissent beaucoup de difficultés
ce qui est pas la même chose ça n'en
fait pas des élèves alors est-ce qu'il
ressemble à ce que les élèves en
difficulté on voit la difficulté pierres
chaudes quand vous décrivez les élèves
du lycée que rencontrent votre votre
héros on peut dire quand même que c'est
vraiment donné au bout du monde
je suis professeur d'université mais
j'ai été professeur pendant dix ans
un peu partout en france donc j'ai fait
toutes sortes d'établissements dont des
établissements de banlieue difficile je
fréquente toujours des professeurs de
collège les professeurs de lycée donc je
pense être quand même un petit peu au
fait de la réalité contemporaine de
l'école je pense que le leem de crise la
roche est un beau livre mais que
l'expérience de crise la roche est une
expérience un peu exceptionnelle qui est
dû en grande partie au syli a une
personnalité exceptionnelle et que enfin
s'ils voulaient elle fait le travail qui
devrait être fait sur l'école mais que
ça ne refais ça ne reflète pas
malheureusement la réalité globale de
l'école aujourd'hui qui est je ne sais
pas si on peut l'améliorer ou faire
quelque chose c'est possible on peut
toujours améliorer faire quelque chose
mais le problème est énorme et vous dis
que le travail après les gigantesques
qui ont peu on peut en parler très
concrètement bien sûr bien sûr vous dit
elle fait le travail ça veut dire risque
la roche vous dites être proviseur ça se
fait avec les pieds c'est à dire il faut
être sur le terrain
il faut être pragmatique il faut faire
des choses précises il faut avoir un
objectif oui bien sûr mais là j'ai rien
inventé je suis pas la seule sur les
collègues font le même travail que moi
les élèves que décrit pierre jourde ses
élèves il faut tout qu'il faut presque
tout un début de cours pour faire
retirer la casquette
ouvrez vous décrivez cette scène où il
faut ouvrir le sac ou ya toute une
chorégraphie une résistance permanente
est ce que c'est les mêmes et des
décérébrés vous dit sans doute c'est
peut-être pas les mêmes profs en tout
cas
franchement j'ai trouvé que toute cette
partie là du roman je la trouve
je la trouve exagérée elle ne plaît pas
parce que j'aime ce roman wick que je le
trouve beau est absolument passionnant
que je trouve que c'est vraiment du
gâchis de l'étayer sur une description
aussi
d'aussi mauvaise foi vous pensez qu'elle
est mauvaise caricatural il ya tous ces
trop quoi votre réponse et bien je crois
que la violence d'abord est globalement
une réalité nouvelle de l'école
d'aujourd'hui et ça serait vraiment
plaisante et que de le nier est non
seulement de l'école mais elle arrive
même j'ai encore écouté la radio
récemment elle arrive jusqu'à
l'université
et on la voit arriver on voit cette
espèce d'invasion encore récemment un
prof dans son amphi qui s'étaient
braqués mais forte averse est incroyable
c'est une réalité qui se globalise hélas
et je veux dire c'est plus possible
comme je vous invite à doisneau venez
voir comme disent les ailes il ya du
respect et plus on en prend l'habitude
nous ça marche
le lycée il est ouvert il ya dix ans 95
vous savez personne n'y croyait on
disait si on construit un lycée
d'enseignement général dans la commune
la plus pauvre de l'ue on va faire un
ghetto si on avait pensé ce que vous
pensez aux leurs et construit ailleurs
son lycée alors et pourtant il marche et
on n'a jamais eu à gérer et de la
violence monumental dans les salles
problème c'est de tomber sur un bon chef
d'établissement c'était les astros
jamais facile j'en ai connu quelques-uns
j'en ai connu quelques-uns dans ma
carrière mais mon expérience et celle de
d'énormément de mes collègues qui sont
qui sont des gens qui souffrent il faut
le dire en silo de heymans de collège
c'est quelqu'un qui souffre et qui
souffre et qui souffre très soul tout
simplement ne pas être soutenus par sa
hiérarchie vous donner un exemple très
concret ma dernière année de profs
il se trouve que bon je crois que
j'étais un bon prof
effectivement je faisais court on se
tenait dans mes cours et en plus j'aime
j'aimais mes élèves et ça marchait ça
marche assez bien
en même temps je me sentais toujours
investie d'une espèce de mission par
exemple de faire la police dans les
couloirs où c'était un bazar absolument
innommable et il se trouve qu'un élève
avait insulté gravement une de mes
collègues et au bout de deux mois au
mois de juin à la fin de l'année ce
garçon qui avait traité sans raison une
prof de [ __ ] tout ce que vous pouvez
gagner tous les noms a été vaguement
exclu deux jours hier qu'il n'avait
absolument rien à faire et c'est comme
ça que ça marche
c'est vrai c'est scandaleux mais vous
pouvez pas dire c'est comme ça que ça
marche on peut pas m'envoyer un fait
divers en me disant c'est comme ça le
système nous présenter dans votre roman
des profs qui sont passifs complètement
votre sera il subit ce système il est
bien malheureux fait son boulot et puis
là tant que ça il attend quoi que le
système
le droit vous faites un travail
admirable et en même temps votre
discours est complice d'un système qui
ne fonctionne pas et qu'ils rendent de
plus en plus produit du non-savoir à
l'université on trouve que les gens qui
sont arrivés jusque là en ayant eu le
bac 80% mais ils réussissent pile ils
réussissent encore pas assez donc il
faut encore se débrouiller pour qu'ils
réussissent plus donc bidouiller les
examens bidouiller les moyens otages et
le système des examens et du cursus est
devenu tellement compliqué à force de
réformes que personne ne comprend plus
rien dans votre livre vous parler du
racisme d'une façon très dur et vous
êtes confrontés aux aidants dans un dans
une mise en scène
je suis absolument accablé par la
régression qui se produit actuellement
au niveau des collèges et des lycées
j'ai des collègues juive qui peuvent pas
avoué dans certaines classes qu'elles
sont juives
c'est quelque chose qui aurait été mais
effarant qu'on a beau dire que
monstrueux il ya encore dix ou quinze
ans je raconte dans le roman effet une
vision une visite avec des élèves ou à
mémorial de la shoah non je sais qu'il y
a agi n'aimait pas du tout ses dires
elle ne s'est pas du tout maintenant il
ya eu un exemple à montreuil justement
vous savez très bien roman qui est
construit des témoignages dit pas
n'importe quoi et je trouve et j'estime
que le roman est parfois une manière
d'aborder la réalité peut être plus
juste et plus direct que peuvent le
faire des enquêtes sociologiques mais
l'ensemble de cette visite c'est elle a
raconté cette visite au mémorial se
permit enfin oui ce consultant avoir des
propos complètement ni négationnistes ou
même on ridiculise les victimes et ce
négationnisme il a cours dans les
collèges et les lycées
quelqu'un se trouve en situation de ne
pas pouvoir dire qu'il est juif c'est
absolument scandaleux
ça veut dire que quelque chose
dysfonctionne dans l'établissement
ouellette je suis d'accord avec vous
c'est l'évidence pas dans les abysses
pas dans l'établissement c'est devenu
une réalité globale
ah non là c'est pas possible c'est pas
vrai
la réalité globale n'est pas celle-là je
suis désolé moi je vis dans un pays où
le racisme
est largement partagé j'ai une fille qui
a la peau très mat et keith entend
souvent dire qu'elle peut retourner dans
son pays
elle se demande bien lequel d'ailleurs
il faut pas non plus oublier des tas de
réalité c'est ambigu
les passages que vous écrivez dans votre
roman là dessus c'est ambigu parce que
vous donnez l'impression que et qu'il
est d'un seul côté le racisme quelle est
la part de romanesque dans dans votre
roman
pour répondre à une question qui n'a pas
été posée est non mais c'est une
question que que je me permets de vous
poser et que vous pouvez dans la réponse
pouvait l'intéresser attristant c'est
peut-être pas un roman autobiographique
c'est un roman qui construit un petit
peu d'expérience personnelle si on ne
parle que de l'école elle n'assure et
beaucoup de synthèse d'effectivement de
témoignages
je voudrais vous dire que le but du
débat n'était pas de dire quand on peut
rien pour l'école vous prouver chaque
jour qu'on peut à partir du moment où on
veut pierre jour se faisait un constat
est en tout cas moi je renvoie tous nos
téléspectateurs à la lecture de vos deux
ouvrages le magnifique roman de pierre
jour festin secret et le rapport d'une
expérience exemplaire et il faut il faut
le dire de crise la roche merci beaucoup
[Musique]
la défense logique de vladimir nabokov
est l'histoire d'un jeune joueur
d'échecs produits qui finira par se
suicider est tendue et difficile de
distinguer le monde réel de celui de
l'échiquier almira skripchenko n'est pas
menacée par ce genre de folie et les né
en urss mais est devenue française par
amour pour paris et pour joël entier le
grand maître des échecs français lé
grand maître international c'est-à-dire
le plus haut grade dans les échecs
elle a été championne du monde à 16 ans
championne d'europe et double championne
de france elle est passionnée de
littérature et nous livre sa lecture du
chez dell de nabokov la défense logique
pas beaucoup je pense que c'est un
magicien de man je pense qu'il ya c'est
un virtuose nabokov lui même peut être
comme soirée un grand musée c'est un
grand joueur d'échecs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
la lecture de soleil en fait il m'a aidé
et peut-être sur sur le sur le plan de
la vie jeu c'est devenu champion du
monde
à 16 ans en fait de ma catégorie et je
voulais
en 16 18 ans il fallait finalement
décédée est ce que je continue mes
études de ce que j'abandonne la voie
traditionnelle tout début de lyon mais
comment un garçon assez singulier
observateur je pense qui a du mal à
exister dans le monde matériel a fait
les deux clubs de son prénom alexandre
enfin nous nous éclaircit en fait sur
plus sur cette personnalité sur le sens
de ce livre
[Musique]
je pense qu'il n'était qu'une pièce de
chèques dans toute cette famille qui se
servait de lui pour l'assouvir se
transpose expiration et le père qui
était c'est venez tôt et qui faisait un
transfert sur ses fautes de ses désirs
le maire qui était un manque de mort du
père qui voulait combler ce vide
puis 26 nov son soi-disant précepteur
mais qu'en fait que sur youtube de son
talent pour gagner beaucoup d'argent
puis plus loin dans les livres sa femme
avec qui ne l'a jamais aimé et je pense
qu'en juin jeu d'échecs qu'il essayé de
renverser le sort parce qu'il vaut mieux
maîtriser quelque chose de
de très logique
il n'a pas fait je pense que l'amour que
j'ai eus que jaloux jean aussi pour le
jeu d'échec ce surtout ils se sentent
d'amour qu'on dirige me même et ça c'est
pas du tout l'amour tu es comme le
perçoit dans la vraie vie étaient tous
les autres cherchent le les réponses
dans les âmes soeurs que je crois pas du
tout
ici
c'est ça l'essence de l'être humain
c'est de ne pas appartenir à ce monde là
c'est de trouver les formes d'expression
qui vous est propre
des paniers et
de se comprendre tant pis pour les
autres s'ils vous comprends pas mais
s'ils le font ça va rester pour
l'éternité
mais il a fini par comprendre la fin il
voulait plus faire partie nous sommes en
a beaucoup fait les cris d'une manière
assez assez profonde
il a fini par voir que cette série de
coups dans la vie tout s'est tu
tout cet amour qu'il n'a jamais eue
notez qu'une combinaison et la fin ils
trouvent que la seule façon de terminer
cette partie ce serait de se suicider
c'est aussi un symbole c'est le symbole
du sacrifice dans le jeu d'échec ce vin
pour pour accéder les mortalités ont
fait un sacrifice cessé dans mon coeur
du plus belle partie
[Musique]
sophie jabès bonsoir ça alors nous
voyons ce soir pour votre dernier roman
[ __ ] motrices paru chez jean claude
lattès et puis pour parler d'une
critique
on y viendra pas d'impatience pas
d'impatience a alors tout d'abord parlé
un petit peu de vous vous êtes un
véritable tour du monde
si j'ai bien noté vous êtes né à milan
enfance aaron études à boston
installé à singapour fixer quelque part
aujourd'hui pour le moment paris à paris
alors qu'une tomate riceys et le
troisième épisode d'une trilogie précédé
par alice la saucisse et puis caroline
assassines qui vient d'obtenir le prix
murat avis c'est un très très grand prix
en fête des livres qui dans lesquels les
femmes revendiquent leur droit à la
différence et leur liberté
alors vous allez répondre à la critique
un peu rock band y en a beaucoup de
jérôme béglé de paris-match navan
comment recevez-vous une mauvaise
critique en général alors ça dépend
comment elle est formulée en fait
quelquefois le move est ce que tu peux
toucher elle peut faire réfléchir à des
pans corps et les formules et si elle
est sincère c'est les authentiques ou
alors si elle est faite juste pour faire
un bon moment alors on va lancer au
ghana
[Musique]
lecture cet automne cet écriteau
motrices ce livre dont de sofia baisse
j'ai presque honte alors gérant béglé a
honte quand on parle de clitoris moi
j'ai envie de dire à jérôme payer mais
faut pas avoir honte
le clitoris en fait c'est quand même un
parties du corps comme une autre comme
lui un pied année et alors jérôme béglé
clitoris clitoris clic c'est pas pour
nous dire peu triste quand il n'y a rien
de plus n'a rien pu normal vraiment y'a
rien que normal donc cool fille qui naît
avec un clitoris de 20 cm à la naissance
très bien rien nous a épargné a grandi
et son petit haut risque grandit encore
plus vite qu'elle au point de dépasser
le maître puis et de mètres et se plie
terisse a une existence par lui même il
parle il se déplace il pense et se
nourrit obligeant alors en fait c'est
vrai que ce qui autorise cela et ça
c'est intéressant ce qu'ils disent est
vraiment intéressant il a une existence
propre
il le sentinel est complètement c'est
son ami en fait c'est l'ami de
clémentine il parle c'est vrai tout à
fait juste c'est un petit peu comme les
bijoux indiscrets du diderot où tout
d'un coup les sexes des femmes se
mettent à parler ou alors le nez de
de gogol qui a une existence propre par
contre je sais pas trop comment
béglé a lieu le bouquin parce qu'il se
nourrit pas si vous ne peut écrire des
bouquins à deux il n'y a pas de problème
je propose 1 95 m quand ils veulent mais
pour voir comment un tuteur le clitoris
peut se nourrir c'est j'avais pas pensé
à ça l'invitation est lancée qui était
déjà prêt très flambard devient
extrêmement grave le ou trois ans ça je
peux pas me laisser passer ça je peux
pas laisser passer koech l'automotrice
un livre grave le si je peux juste lui
accorder si on pense que graveleux ça
veut dire à la fois un livre grave et un
livre heureux parce que c'est vrai que
c'est plutôt un livre sur le bonheur qui
est tombé là vous faites un mot valise
avec france pâtit du pas totale et le
sens pas là mais sinon c'est pas du tout
grave le sait absolument ni graveleux ni
obscène et je crois qu'en fait
l'explication de ce mot dans les bouches
de géronte dans la bouche pardon dire
mais béglé c'est que c'est qu'il a honte
qu'il n'est pas à l'aise n'a pas l'air
d'être très à l'aise avec le corps de la
femme un sidération du père de cette
pauvre clémente y aura droit au regard
un peu étonné des hommes est d'ailleurs
des femmes aussi qu'elle croise et son
clitoris lui dicte un comportement qui
est évidemment un comportement anormal
anormal non ça s'est fait sur le soutien
parce que c'est vrai que tu te quitte au
risque clémentine clémentine au début
elle se croit tout à fait normal pour
elle c'est totalement normal d'avoir un
très grand guitariste et c'est les
autres
si le regard des autres qui va faire
qu'elle va se vivre qu'elle va se penser
qu'elle va se sentir différentes banques
au fur et à mesure de ce petit livre
c'est plus femme à barbe c'est la pharma
lotto avec un couteau motrices démentiel
tout est vulgaire
j'ai alors tout est vulgaire j'aimerais
bien qu'ils me disent et ce qui est
vulgaire
parce qu'en fait parler du corps de la
femme c'est pas vulgaire parler du grand
amour parce que clémentine elle va vivre
un très très bel amour à la fin c'est
pas vulgaire et ce qui pourrait
éventuellement prête à confusion
il ya effectivement une scène qui
pourrait prêter à confusion dans le
livre c'est une scène ou clémentine est
très proche de son père et on pourrait
dire un maintien est atteint il ya un 16
tout est en fait non c'est pas ça joue
vraiment le de souligner parce qu'on a
pu aussi me le reprocher la tentation
d'inceste et à fantasmes d'inceste on a
plein de choses qui circulent dans la
tête
en fait je dis tout haut ce qu'on pense
vraiment tout bas mais en fait il n'ya
rien de tel qui se passe absolument rien
au contraire le père est garant pour sa
fille de la barrière entre elle et sa
mère il joue pleinement son rôle de père
et c'est grâce à lui d'ailleurs qu'elle
va pouvoir s'autoriser à vivre l'amour
j'ai jamais trouvé une
un gramme de poésie une once de phrases
bien écrite et âme et littérature alors
y'a jamais littérature en fait jérôme
béglé me fait penser à ces critiques qui
comme les impressionnistes sont arrivés
entre guillemets sur le marché on dit
ce n'est pas de la peinture et qui ne se
soit attaché qu'au sujet par exemple
pour le pour le tableau d'edouard manet
le déjeuner sur l'herbe
une certaine partie de la critique a
crié à l'obscénité mabiala la famille
d'un milieu entre deux hommes habillés
voilà c'était ça et dans le fond il ya
une femme qui se baignent dans l'eau et
en fait on a vu que la chair comme sa
fraîche il ya pas d'autres mots et
jérôme béglé c'est la même chose
il voit un bout de clitoris une voie que
ça il est obnubilé par ce alors il
trouve sa bile guerre et trouve que ce
n'est pas la littérature c'est
exactement la même chose que de dire que
les doormen s est pas de la peinture
alors on va me dire va me trouver un peu
cuistre mais tant pis je prends le
risque parce que ce livre je l'adorent
d'autres que moi nador on y viendra très
vite dans ce cas je crois que j'ai
compris finalement ce que je cherchais
l'auteur se refuse à metz elle est
publiée l'année dernière il ya deux ans
de livres qui avait eu un succès on va
dire des steam
il y avait rencontré quelques bonnes
critiques quelques libraires favorable
et quelques acheteurs pas très nombreux
et là il s'est dit il faut faire une
bonne polémique un beau scandale pour
être sûr qu'on vous remarque pour être
sûr que en fin de droits des quelques
lignes après scandaleuse qui font vendre
mon livre donc elle s'est jetée à corps
perdu là dedans alors corps perdu non
c'est pas du tout mais alors pas du tout
du corps perdu c'est du corps retrouvés
c'est l'histoire d'une fille qui tout
d'un coup ce bois différentes se sent
rejetée et qui peu à peu à peu va
comprendre qu'est ce que ça veut dire
d'être une femme qu'est ce que ça veut
dire les choses extraordinaires pour
d'être une femme parce que justement une
double sexualité et une sexualité
extérieur il ya aussi une sexualité
intérieure et dans le livre au début
clémentine elle fait un peu comme jérôme
béglé elle est au menu bill et par les
autres elle est obnubilé par cette
grande
et puis tout d'un coup grâce un homme
d'ailleurs adrien qu'elle va adorer qui
va beaucoup l'aimer elle va se rendre
compte qu'être une femme ccl2 sexualité
c'est l'intérieur et l'extérieur et
c'est aussi des sentiments
voilà malheureusement c'est totalement
raté
moi j'avais le coeur au bord des lèvres
quasiment première première page et à
aucun moment elle essaie de retrouver
une histoire qui se tiennent alors ça
c'est important c'est important parce
que justement ce qui m'intéresse
vraiment c'est de raconter des histoires
c'est d'ailleurs j'écris toujours la fin
avant le début c'est la première chose
et deuxièmement c'est le titre qui est
premier c'est que j'ai eus [ __ ] motrice
dans ma tête et ensuite j'écris et c'est
vraiment vraiment c'est très très
important vous d'écrire des histoires
c'est fondamental et c'est vraiment des
comptes en plus donc histoire est très
importante
il ya plein de passage que je pourrais
lire bon j'aurais choisi un comme ça
c'est au début du livre la mer qui va
réveiller sa fille en disant que cette
attaque il faut trouver une solution
la mère parler vite les mots se
bousculent est incongru dans le noir de
la nuit
mais maman je dors et bien réveille toi
l os à la voix n'en peut plus un peu
plus de te voir comme ça tu ne sors plus
tu restes seul toute la journée bientôt
qui refusera même de passer des examens
nous avons décidé avec ton père il faut
couper couper clémentine dormait à
moitié à serra sont lisses parfumer avec
ses mains coupées quoi ton truc il faut
le couper
tu ne trouveras jamais amaris tu
continues comme ça elle leva les yeux au
ciel et s'assied sur le libre est la
fille repousse à la fleur de courgette
d'un revers de la main lui caressa les
cheveux tu es d'accord c'est pas une vie
c'est vrai que c'est pas une vie de lire
des livres comme ça ça a compris
pourquoi il était précipitée ont été ce
texte qui est l'hôte à la hauteur de
cette maison d'édition pas à l'honneur
de son auteur et surtout qui est je
trouve extrêmement méprisant extrêmement
dégradants alors ça je crois vraiment de
saint contraire c'est un livre
absolument pas ni méprisant et dégradant
pour la femme
au contraire c'est un hymne à la
féminité clémentine elle va se retrouver
ce qui est dégradant c'est une femme
violée c'est une femme qu'on méprise
c'est une femme qu on excise ça c'est
dégradant et je crois en tout cas ce que
doit déranger su bien réfléchi je pense
vraiment que ce qui doit déranger c'est
qu'on a quand les femmes dernièrement on
parlait de sexe c'est soit sur un ton
cliniques comme catherine millet par
exemple il ya eu partout des compagnies
dans les livres de 4000 ouvriers et
d'ailleurs elle peut dire ce qu'elle
veut c'est ya aucun souci mais ces
cliniques
quand par exemple breillat ou même
virginie despentes écrivent aussi sur la
sexualité féminine
c'est vrai que c'est assez violent quand
même cette sexualité qu'ils aient pensé
beaucoup en terme de viol en est le
rapport entre les sexes entre hommes et
femmes en tant qu affrontements temps
que lui dans ton cul guerre ce livre
c'est un livre qui pense une sexualité
féminine apaisé qui y croit un peu
encore aux bienfaits de l'amour et aux
bienfaits du sexe alors
moi aussi je prends bien fait de la
burqa fait du sexe car ce sont les
propos qui vont vous réconcilier à la
fin tous les deux peut-être moi je te
conseille en tout cas de relire le livre
quand il le verra démission parce que il
aura là le meilleur ou en tout cas un
meilleur moment de lecture puisqu'il a
bien voulu dire en tout cas c'était un
plaisir de parler avec vous se figea
baisse de quito motrices et et d'écouter
la critique de jérôme béglé alors il
faut dire aux thèmes de 2,2 de cet
entretien que c'est pas facile dans quoi
on remercie jérôme bel initialement
acquis à cet exercice parce que vous
savez et vous savez très bien que
d'autres qui n'ont pas ce courage là
donc c'était intéressant et important
qui se confrontent à vous et je pense
que vous l'avez montré du courage et je
crois que vous avez très bien s'il avait
eu besoin d'être défendus vous avez très
bien parlé de votre livre je pense que
beaucoup de nos téléspectateurs ont
envie de les lire encore plus et
j'espère parce qu'en fait sa une sur le
bonheur aussi
voilà merci
on
ce soir pour notre cours de littérature
marc levy nous parle de jacques prévert
marc levy est un véritable phénomène
dans l'édition française
souvenez-vous en l'an 2000 son premier
roman et si c'était vrai a été le roman
le plus vendu en france en 2003 ou
laitue dans la version poche a été le
roman le plus vendu en france 2003
encore sept jours pour l'éternité
le roman le plus vendu en france est
aujourd'hui marc levy sort vous revoir
qui est la suite de et si c'était vrai
qui va être adapté au cinéma et sortir
le 23 novembre donc marc levy ces
phénomènes et on pourrait dire que il
ressemble un espèce d'inventaire à la
prévert un inventaire du succès c'est
peut-être ça qui conduit aujourd'hui
marc levy à nous parler de jacques
prévert on va lui demander s'il ne monte
pas un petit [ __ ] laveur dans cette
énumération marc bonjour
en fait c'est le contraire j'étais
mauvais élèves
j'étais très mauvais élève est dans la
salle de classe sur mon pupitre au fond
près de la fenêtre
j ai découvert l'ennui et surtout une
vraie solitude qui était la solitude du
mauvais élève très éloignés de ceux des
premiers rangs et puis un jour notre
professeur de français
elle s'appelait madame delvaux je crois
est rentré dans la classe elle est
montée sur l'estrade est là elle avait
un livre dans les mains et elle a dit il
dit non avec la tête mais
dit oui avec le coeur il dit oui à ce
qu'il aime il dit non aux professeurs il
est debout on le questionne et tous les
problèmes sont posés
c'est grâce à ces mots de jacques
prévert que j'ai pour la première fois
de ma vie découvert cette alchimie
incroyable de ligne qui tout à coup vous
emmène dans un ailleurs dans une autre
vie que la vôtre qui peuvent faire
sortir évader un prisonnier de n'importe
quelle cellule quelle que soit la
cellule qui l'entourent et j'ai gardé un
souvenir inouïe de ce moment-là
peut-être parce que au travers de ses
premiers mots de jacques prévert
j'ai aussi découvert une des valeurs que
mon père relaiera toute sa vie et dieu
merci il est encore en vie qui est celle
de la liberté et du respect de la
liberté des autres
c'est absolument bouleversant enfin
touchant de voir à quel point
prévert est un poète intemporel il ya un
tout un texte de lui que je voudrais
vous lire parce qu'il est il est
tellement à l'image de son centre
d'intérêt mais je vais vous demander une
petite seconde
brasset la bouche voilà étranges
étrangers kabyle de la chapelle et des
quêtes javel sommes des pays loin
cobayes des colonies d'où petits
musiciens cela les adolescents de la
porte d'italie gougnan de la porte de
saint-ouen apatrides d'aubervilliers
brûlures des grandes ordures de la ville
de paris est bouillante heures des bêtes
trouvées mortes sur pied au beau milieu
des rues tunisien de grenelle embaucher
et débaucher manoeuvre désoeuvrés polak
du marais du temple des rosiers
cordonnier de cordoue soutiers de
barcelone pêcheurs des baléares ou du
cap finistère rescapés de franco et
déportés de france et de navarre pour
avoir défendu en souvenir de la vôtre la
liberté des autres esclaves noirs de
fréjus tiraillé et parqués au bord d'une
petite mer ou peu vous vous baignez
esclaves noirs de fréjus qui évoqué
chaque soir dans les locaux
disciplinaire avec une vieille boîte à
cigares et quelques bouts de fil de fer
tous les échos de vos villages tous les
oiseaux de vos forêts et ne venez dans
la capitale que pour fêter au pas
cadencé la prise de la bastille le 14
juillet enfants du sénégal
des patrouilles et expatriés et
naturalisé enfants indochinois jongleurs
aux innocents couteau qui vendit
autrefois aux terrasses des cafés de
jolis dragon d'or fait de papier pliée
enfants trop tôt grandi et si vite en
aller qui dormaient aujourd'hui de
retour au pays le visage dans la terre
et des bombes
dire la bourre en vo rizières on vous a
renvoyé la monnaie de vos papiers dorés
on vous a retourné au petit couteau dans
le dos étrange étranger vous êtes de la
ville vous êtes de sa vie même si mal
ans vivait même si vous en mourrez
alors je trouve que aujourd'hui quarante
ans plus tard voire cinquante ans plus
tard duke ce texte est d'actualité
jacques prévert a écrit que son enfance
avait été la plus fastueuse des misères
d'abord je crois qu'à l'origine il ya
entre lui et son père une relation
merveilleuse une relation comme on en
lit dans les livres et si je tu peux
dire juste une chose je crois que ce qui
m'a rapproché de prévert c'est mon père
pas parce que mon père me parlait de
prévert mais parce que j'avais avec vous
j'ai eu avec mon père toute ma vie
exactement cette relation le le père de
jacques prévert qui était critique de
cinéma et théâtre l'emmener au cinéma et
lui a appris la magie du rêve et de la
réalité confondues et en se faisant il a
ouvert à son fils la porte de tous les
espoirs
la porte de toutes les libertés la porte
de tous les deux venir et surtout la
réponse absolue à tous les impossibles
et c
je crois l'une des plus belles choses
qu'on puisse transmettre parce que je ne
crois pas que ça s'enseigne je crois que
ça se donne avec le choeur avec les
tripes avec énormément d'amour
moi je sais que mon père m'a
probablement inventé ma conscience
le jour il m'a emmené voir par et
chocolat et puis l'histoire à des à des
jeux lire tour parce que bien des années
plus tard alors que j'avais lu prévert
et qu'ils étaient devenus des jeunes les
auteurs cultes
mon père qui était éditeur d'art un jour
a publié une collection de l'oeuvre de
jacques prévert illustré par un immense
artiste qui vient de nous quitter et qui
a été pour moi je crois un des artistes
qui m'a le plus touché par ce que lui
aussi m'a ouvert les portes de la
peinture c'était jean-michel foulon et
tout à coup dans ces pages
que mon père inventaire en composant les
textes de prévert avec les dessins de
jean michel folon alors toute la magie
de ces deux artistes secret
prenez naissance sous mes yeux
d'adolescents qui regardaient le travail
s'accomplir sur une table et les
bonhommes de folon qui s'envolait comme
ça dans des couchers de soleil
redessinait les mots libre de jacques
prévert
alors je crois que toute ma vie jacques
prévert sera comme un guide 7 7 suivi
cette petite lumière que je ne veux
jamais oubliée qui est celle de se dire
que quoi qu'il vous arrive ce qui arrive
aux autres est encore plus important
l'archiviste roots un très bel hommage à
prévert un très émouvant hommage à votre
père à la liberté et au petit cancre qui
un jour devient marc levy
[Musique]
depuis 1996 et et le succès considérable
de truismes on croit connaître marie
darrieussecq
dans son dernier roman le pays paru chez
un pel sont héroïne s'interroge sur sa
vie et son histoire le temps d'une
grossesse et d'un retour au pays
dans son journal intime marie
darrieussecq nous parle avec une grande
liberté
une belle jubilation et de superbes
mains de jogging de sexe et de nathalie
sarraute
alors oui non on est fliqué lie à une
télé je peux pas te parler ça va aller
d'accord cha cha quelques rires ah ça
c'est assez fou qui m'écrivait celui
papier génique avec des poils il
écrivait sur du papier hygiénique des
insultes très élaborés et il y avait des
poils pubiens dans cette enveloppe qui
m'envoyait j'allais garder certaines des
espèces d'objets un peu de la datura de
64 kg pas peur des microbes
toutes ces énormes peur là qu'on balance
pour consomment davantage
toute cette transformation du désir
en commerçant assez fatigant parce
qu'elle a compris que l'être humain
n'était pas fait de bosser c'est tout et
que vettel a inventé ce truc génial
d'être enfin car l'allemand on travaille
le mieux c'est quand même but
enfin vive le droit seul moment où je
suis toute seule dans ma tête c'est
quand je cours
c'est l'échappée quoi une partie de mon
cerveau qui va régler des petits
problèmes matériels une autre qui va
vers la table des phrases on arriver
plus tôt et une autre je suis pas là où
je suis un peu comme quand on dort une
espèce de rêve
j'aime énormément cet état c'est un
message à mon avis le jogging c'est la
méditation occidentale du passé une
sorte de de porosité au monde
c'était là dessus tu raisonnes plus en
termes dgo tu
ces traversées par leur part tu sens la
planète sous tes pieds parce que tu là
martèle je sais pas il ya un état
physique hyper agréable et où justement
il ya un moment tu sais quand on court
on sent plus son corps non plus où on
est d'une espèce de légèreté on est une
bulle et là j'ai vraiment l'impression
que le monde traverse est très très
agréable et là c'est une sorte de point
d'origine pour l'écriture
[Musique]
on voit rock avait vidé de façon trop
croisée des écrivains âgées certains
jeunes et donc j'avais emporté sa route
et en fait on s'est tous mis d'accord
elle salue peazip allait laver un
rapport très compliqué à la presse puis
est très agité et donc à ma demande et
qu'on le fasse plus cet entretien enfin
alors que tout était prêt et moi elle me
plaisait tellement j'ai préféré à me
fâcher et du coup on est devenus très
copines quoi et je les connais quatre
ans elle est morte et presque s'entend
mais la raconter des trucs dément elle a
raconté qu'elle était fâchée avec son
père parce que elle elle était
bolchévique et le match épique en 17 tu
vois elle est connue tout le monde puis
casse-croûte picasso c'est un petit
jeune du bon a été très mal et puis on
l'a vu je sais pas quoi fin il y avait
un côté était tellement elle avait une
telle ville était tellement là j'ai
aussi
recul et elle était très angoissée aussi
des sites s est pas du tout sereine et à
moi ça me plaisait bien est ce que
j'aime et c'est qu'elle était hyper
obstiné ça c'est un truc elle m'a pris
pas lâché par la chine envers et contre
tout les bonnes ni mauvaises critiques
les gays les autres en général si tu
veux à écrire à tenir et en 96 avait
besoin de quelqu'un me dise ça tu vois
les 21 maelström médiatique autour de
truismes elle devenue une sorte de point
fixe
[Musique]
j'aimais faire un musée c'était le
copain de freud
parce que c'est un grand poète justement
parce que parce qu'ils expliquent que ce
qu'il appelle le coït qui peut être qui
pour lui est une catastrophe parce que
ça à l'écrivain la catastrophe ça
j'adore ça le coït état de tension comme
ça d'un cheminement et pis elle parle
très bien la famille colruyt est une
catastrophe et je trouve ça très beau on
devrait parler de la masturbation
féminine on ne parle pas assez simple
inspiration s'attarder soi même mais
quand j'écris je m'absente que l'autre
est là justement je deviens suffisamment
appelons ça absente
pourquoi y ait de la présence qui arrive
j'aime beaucoup cette idée que faire la
musique c'est aussi lié au fait d'avoir
des enfants
quelque chose qu'on n'oublie optik gmbh
pour voir les enfants arrivent et ne
rien faire contre le fait de voir les
enfants sur sa boutique
l'écriture est loin et le type de bout
en bout c'est-à-dire qu'elle reprend
toutes les perversions d'érotisme pas au
sens où freud disait que quand ils
n'étaient que perversion quoi est aussi
l'enfantement mais aussi la caresse
enfin l'érotisme ses parents deviennent
trop quand enfin on peut espérer ce à
quoi courir nager sur l'amour et
l'écrire
[Musique]
marie sizun bonsoir alors vous est ce
soir notre inattendue pour votre roman
le père de la petite votre premier roman
alors peut-être que le téléspectateur se
dit mais est ce vraiment son premier
roman
elle est vraiment inattendu est ce que
je peux en toute amitié vous demander
votre âge à wil 65 corps voilà 65 ans
pour écrire son premier roman
on va essayer de voir s'il ya une raison
alors d'abord vous avez eu un parcours
de deux professeurs
il avait été très longtemps
professionnel et très longtemps
professeur j'ai écrit deux petites
choses mais que je ne je n'ai jamais
essayé d'oublier ah bon j'avais peu de
temps et je rêvais d'arriver un jour à
écrire un roman mais quand j'aurai le
temps et puis elle quand même les contes
de fées c'est à dire vous avez envoyé ce
roman-là votre éditeur arléa enfin ce
qui est maintenant votre éditeur et on
vous a répondu presque immédiatement
puisque presque immédiatement parce que
je les déposer chez hervé à un
après-midi et le lendemain matin la
directrice m'a téléphoné en me disant
j'ai adoré venez nous voir ça ça fait
toujours mal
voilà plaisir à tous ceux qui ont des
embarras ou des difficultés pour être
édité c'est toujours ça existe ça existe
alors ça existe et puis franchement le
conte de fées va jusqu'au bout parce que
c'est assez un livre merveilleux moi je
les dis d dès l'introduction j'adore vos
clics vous dis tout de suite maintenant
on va quand même en parler alors le père
de la petite le titre qu'est ce que ça
signifie
j'évolue le titre le plus simple
possible c'est à dire quelque chose
d'anonymes
qui met en scène le père et puis une
petite fille et la relation qui
s'établit entre eux alors il ya d'abord
une situation initiale qui est quand
même particulière le père de la petite
est prisonnier de guerre la petite vie
avec sa mère à paris on né en 1944 et on
attend le retour du père en même temps
qu'on attend la libération de paris
voilà elle n'a jamais vu son père et
puis un beau jour ce père va débarquer
mais ça se passera très mal parce que
elle le considère vraiment comme un
intrus il est lui-même déséquilibré par
les années de captivité il est très dur
et l'enfant est malheureuse et jalouse
aussi de cet homme qui lui prend sa mère
oui parce qu'il faut dire que auparavant
bien évidemment elle vivait presque en
symbiose complète avec sa mère et une
grand-mère pour avec le club de tir des
petits tiraillements et dans un premier
temps le père qui donc fini par revenir
avec une espèce d'étrangers d'intrus
qu'elle retrouve un matin dans son lit
absolument alors c'est toute l'évolution
de cette petite alors je fais et elie
parce que dès maintenant j'aimerais
justement que que vous lisiez ce
paragraphe où la petite fille un matin
ce réveil et son père est là c'est ce
passage que j'aime beaucoup quand elle
s'est réveillée le lendemain matin elle
avait un peu oublié elle a voulu aller
voir sa mère comme elle fait d'habitude
et quand elle a ouvert la porte de sa
chambre elle s'est rappelée les choses
dans le grand lit encore profondément
endormie il y avait deux personnes
sa mère est quelqu'un d'autre son père
la petite a refermé la porte
voilà il était là elle avait un père
voilà
et ces quelques lignes 10 le caractère
trempé de cette petite fille parce qu'on
va l'avoir avoir qui tous les sentiments
naja louzy la violence une petite fille
qui son père dirait qu'elle est mal
élevé parce qu'elle a été élevée
très librement par sa mère ah oui elle
faisait ce qu'elle voulait elle
dessinait sur les murs elle chantait
très fort elle mangeait ce qu'elle
voulait alors qu'on était en temps de
guerre et que c'est pas tout à fait
correct et le père a va essayer de la
mettre au pas c'est un des aspects
de lui qu'elle va détester et puis se
passe quelque chose d'incroyable c'est
que il ya un renversement de situation
sa mère lui échappe et elle va se
rapprocher tout doucement du père et
c'est prendre véritablement de de son
père là il ya alors cette petite on
appelle toujours la petite on
l'appellera toujours la petitesse apple
france comme la france mais ça n'est pas
important dans le livre je crois que
c'est ça reste la petite et vous tenez à
ce qu'elle reste à ce qu'elle reste la
petite mais il ya quelque chose qu'on a
oublié de dire c'est qu'il y a un secret
il ya une intrigue parallèle qui court à
travers le roman c'est ce secret dont
elle a saisit des bribes et qui va dans
la confiance est perdue qu'elle va vous
elle son père elle va lâcher le secret
bon il faut pas trop en main nous on en
aurait finalement ça va déclencher une
espèce de séismes dans cette dans cette
famille qui était en train de se
reconstituer
elle a publié des très très entier et
c'est très important pour elle qu'on la
croit c'est très important pour elle que
les adultes représentent la vérité nous
les enfants pour tous les enfants c'est
très important
et là elle est prise et effectivement
dans une espèce de drames personnels on
ne la croit pas il n'existe pas si on ne
la croit pas et elle s'adresse à son
père comme à la seule personne qui qui
est capable de la croire justement
malheureusement ça va être ça tournait
mal donc c'est une est une espèce
d'histoire d'amour malheureux entre un
enfant et son père qu'elle se trouve
très beau dans ce livre c'est que cette
petite fille a des absences elle oublie
comme la mémoire fait mais elle oublie
même des choses extrêmement importantes
c'est à dire dans le paragraphe que vous
avez lu la juste avant le père ante
elle ne sait pas si c'est le jour ou la
nuit et moi j'aime bien cette idée comme
ça que la mémoire laisse des blancs oui
face à sienne aussi un peu le travail du
romancier de donner cette impression
justement de d'authenticité et trous de
la mémoire et puis au contraire des
éclairs défiguration du souvenir ca c
mais nous préparons notre mémoire et un
disque qui fait le romanesque
ce qui fait la mythologie parce que il y
a pour pour moi quand je lis ce livre là
je trouve que on ressent très très bien
l'enfant et que j'avais presque dire
qu'on ne regarde pas j'ai le bonheur
d'avoir une petite fille qu'on ne
regarde pas son enfant de la même façon
on se dit est ce qu'elle ressent tout ça
est ce qu elle me regarde comme ça ça
c'est ce que je voudrais vraiment
arriver à faire pour beaucoup de pères
qui vous regardent et peut-être leurs
enfants différemment il ya un potentiel
de d'intelligence de sensibilité chez
l'enfant bien une gravité est aussi que
souvent les adultes mais connaissent
c'est grave d'être un enfant on ressent
des choses qui sont qui sont terribles
et et ça justement tout ce qu'elle peut
peut découvrir à ce moment là je pense
que ça c'est une histoire qui pourrait
être une histoire adultes ce qu'elle vit
mais à l'échelle d'un enfant au terme de
cet entretien je voulais vous poser une
question je sais que vous êtes peintre
je veux c'est qu'il ya quelque part du
côté de l'étudier des expositions qu'on
peut visiter par jour vous poser une
question qui a peut-être paraître
bizarre
est-ce que vous avez pas la petite
jamais j'ai jamais plein de personnages
je n'aimais pas ça mais si je veux
imaginer la petite je représenterai il
ya un tableau de modigliani que vous
connaissez certainement la petite fille
en bleu on voit une petite fille un peu
penché comme tous les personnages de
modigliani un peu triste et c'est comme
ça quand j'imagine rêve tout cas marie
sizun moi je voudrais vous remercier
d'abord pour le bonheur que vous m'avez
donné et l'émotion à lire ce livre je
vous conseille vraiment à tout le monde
de lire le père de la petite sécher
arléa premiers milles
j'espère que demain matin dans toutes
les librairies on n'aura plus un sol
alors vous êtes très gentil garçon très
grand plaisir à bavarder avec merci
beaucoup je me permets une aisselle
david oui ça j'ai un petit coup de blues
de ce soir toi ce livre que tu vois là
c'est le dernier numéro de la série
noire en petit format numéro 2743
dernier coup de kenyatta c'est un nom
presque prédestiné un livre de donald
going pourquoi j'ai un petit buzz parce
que moi j'ai ya plus de dix ans et édité
dans la dans la série noire alors la
série noire maintenant ce sera du grand
format et le premier roman c'est thomas
sanchez king bongo une histoire qui se
passe à cuba avant la révolution
castriste du temps de tous les de tous
les trafics
voilà alors j'aimerais que tu lis et ses
deux livres la lave a qui vont
maintenant peut-être devenir collector
alors quand à nous aux lakers oui ce
soir café picouly est terminée nous on
se retrouve pour une nouvelle émission
dans quinze jours
est ce que tu te souviens du but premier
numéro de la série noire seulement pas
là peter chainel à monde vert de gris et
oui une adaptation avec eddie
constantine
[Musique]
dans quinze jours
à
[Musique]
rabat l'égail sont pas saines